hey guys hey mater what's going on yeah
[Laughter]
it's a pump glad you're here miss taro
we were just listening to the new Taylor
Swift song so you're the guy you're the
guy to talk to about for me yeah I was
way worse I get him back sometimes I get
poo shy yeah who shines Jessie it was so
what the [ __ ] is that mic out there it's
the worst a little bit like a bull in a
china shop
the mic Frankenmuth little bit Matt Matt
has a great post dumped glow so happy to
me hi Jimmy
hey buddy good to see you everything I'm
not nasty I washed my hands the news I'm
not throwing anybody in the bus I didn't
know the dude that walked in after me
but he that [ __ ] didn't wash his
hands and that's kind of nasty every
time I change his [ __ ] she starts
running in circles cuz she's so excited
I feel like that's the that's the spot
that Matt Serra isn't in his life right
now oh no you know what it is I normally
can I control it [ __ ] headphone
things on this yeah yeah the volumes
write everything from you yeah such a
prima donna lately so you're a--you're
you're an expert yeah I usually start my
day with the role I get my jujitsu in
but I usually slide I do too it gets
back to the shits back to my [ __ ]
when I when I do that it like this I
listen I think a lot of shits I'm very
regular when I wake up in the morning
right I would double shot of espresso
and I uh and I go downstairs so I don't
wake my wife in my own bathroom and I I
have a double shot of espresso and I
have a whole thing of a seltzer water
flavored club soda okay it's [ __ ]
delicious fresh Italian you know it is
and I do that on my iPhone and it gets
things going Jimmy and and then I do
like my first my first like like like
dump of the day right okay and then like
I meet my buddies over at my school I
get ready and everything and then after
I roll when you do jujitsu you've
constantly rolling it strangler people
good not to get strangled and taken
limbs then it moves things around sure
at least take another one after that
when you get strangled does it make you
have to [ __ ] I mean push it out it's
like me on belly on you that sounds a
little equity point that towards your
sounding a little echoing and he's not
part enough that loud alright yeah it's
not you as good Mike is it okay it
sounds a little echoey to me beer at
two-a-days right now at least well then
after that Jimmy could attest this and
then I get to the city to you to the
studio and I always give Jimmy first
dibs on the bathroom because I'm cuz I
like Jimmy a lot it's very courteous
I'll walk and he'll go like you need the
bathroom and give me the option because
he's never in there and I wait I wait a
little bit too even if I'm holding it in
a little bit like so today it threw me
off so like I I went this morning but
I'm like I know I spy some [ __ ] I
know I got some so then I was okay on
the train but then I got here you have a
[ __ ] open about a kid and like the
fake nuts and the [ __ ] snakes come
out get off my ass now it was never st
Sam Roberts the same uh yeah it is so
wait so when you but when you were
fighting did you ever like have to [ __ ]
while you were in the Octagon no but
that is a fear right I remember once I
nice to make 155 and then it was so it
was so like [ __ ] a hundred pounds ago
with you know but it was it was rough
man cuz even though I'm not a tall man
I'm very wide like 155 I was like a
tweener like if there was like a 165 or
even 160 that would have been great for
me in my prime but 155 I was pretty
rough to get down so I was always eating
almost up until I uh I had to go down in
the fight so I know Ben's always a
Eagles man stop [ __ ] eating you see
pitbulls when they fight me scared so I
instantly put down the [ __ ] someone
has someone has [ __ ] in the ring who is
the woman that just happened Jessica
just chillin you talking about she
fought um she fought Felice Herrig yes
there's videos called two girls one cage
you made that up and the girl shorts are
so I mean [ __ ] is come out there's no
room in there she made fun she dress on
side so maybe if she made fun of it did
you tap out and keep fighting she's a
show but that's got to be tough for
fighting strategy right when you're
sitting there like I got a strategy
going in but now in the back your mind
oh no now I'm also worried about [ __ ] I
ain't never really know I never really
had that much of a problem with it but I
would have a Chris Chris Weidman yeah
had the he had the [ __ ] before he fought
um
Vitor Belfort thank god he took that
[ __ ] out quick he's looking out
in the first round cuz you know five
REMS it was champ so that would've been
25 minutes of looking to do bodily harm
while you're holding in your your cup of
duty but he but he felt it as his walk
into the ring but he's walking to the
range like you had to show right before
like he had to do it right before we
walked out so he's the second guy to
walk out and then he didn't say it then
but uh he told me right afterwards man
he had to take a [ __ ] because y'all I
felt that right before I'm like that's
what motivated him to finish it telling
Matt it was great you have a cup the
cups that they wear though it's not just
like a regular Cup where you slip it in
I mean some of those cups are pretty
intricate the way they put them on you
can't just take him off and take a [ __ ]
or can you is your is your [ __ ]
available yeah I mean isolate that
that's a great clip right it's not just
a slippery top right no it's the one
where you stay I mean I guess people got
differ
things some guys use the ones like the
they get the tie around the my weight I
just like stepped in it so if I was
wearing nothing right you'd see my ass
but you wouldn't see my [ __ ] and balls
like the old [ __ ] locker room
[Laughter]
expresso and dirty work whatever I could
do to poopoo no Jimmy tell you about my
regular 43 year old say this D tell you
about my new game I got virtual reanima
reality system virtual reality's crazy
can play with that it's [ __ ] crazy
yes I did it in the mall you can you can
try it out in the mall the Xbox the
Microsoft Store in the mall you can you
can try the whole system on in the mall
you have to sign a waiver they show
people falling weight well Mike could
you step off a cliff virtual reality you
put it on and you can fight somebody or
climb a mountain but not an Xbox thing
Microsoft has a it's not an Xbox it's a
Microsoft has a virtual reality games
and goggles where you can go to the
store you're thinking of this [ __ ] you
see in Best Buy dude I will [ __ ] go
to that Microsoft with the v IV e 5v the
[ __ ] house you're fired up man you
are all fired come in [ __ ] live I've
actually watched yeah I've watched porn
Wow on this stuff you can nobody did you
really you know I actually did it a
comedy club the comedy connection Rhode
Island the guy had it and I put it on
I'm at the bar there was around 10
people there after the show waitresses
and waiters instead I started pumping
it's you can look around the room look
around the room and the girl you can you
can look down at your it's not your car
it was such a better [ __ ] than mine too
hard you look down at Gina she's she's
riding you're facing it's the key like
it was it was the craziest [ __ ] ever and
we put the good we put them on a girl
and she was looking around the room
she's like oh I love that countertop and
the kid that's all when you look down
it's a video game can you like give you
some big nah it's a bit you know it's a
video not a video game it's actually
when you watch porn
yeah it's vr porn you can look around
the room you can look at the girl you
look like looking at [ __ ] or look at
the titties we've been talking about
this the other day me and Jimmy and
remember when you well if you ever got
corded jerking off hugging me Becca yeah
it's like an instant where you might
lock your eyes or something that it
stops attached to the headset yeah if
you're walking off with this people
gonna throw something at you exactly I
it's so real yeah that my she was on me
she got up on me and she was riding me
so I I just started I had a throw them
off I was like I gotta get these off cuz
you're humping the air in the comedy
club yeah Bailey Jays doing it now Matt
is doing a VR porn so you'll be able to
like you know in that gym I I think I
would really enjoy Bailey's VR porn
people be running around cute going Jim
what are you doing jump not making the
yummy noise floor do they have any like
Becca okay
yeah show Madsen belly Jay she's cute
[ __ ] yeah yeah if you can find some
nudes of Bayley J now I'm like oh she's
would you just go to like the bikini
shop first
yeah somebody's very hot she heard her
husband we know and she's doing some VR
porn
she's pretty does she have a penis
before I say anything I don't know that
sense is a stirring in your loins if you
went right to that you'll be able to go
to her pay her a thousand whatever you
pay her do shoot the porn with her like
say you [ __ ] her and then you'd have
your own virtual porn with you in it so
when you look down watch your dick at
your leg at your hands I'd be so scared
to watch anything to whack go off with
that thing on man and that's crazy yeah
beyond like a like a bolted door
somebody comes in you're not gonna stop
did you were you watching porn kids he
took it in a literal way you know what I
mean when you have kids you can't you
can't okay hold on now everyone's
jumping to conclusions
there's no time with a kid in the house
like you can't even like when usually
why is to masturbate in the bathroom but
you look down you see like scuba jo it's
like a forget it yeah that could lose
the kids you see a kid's toy right yeah
it's more about like screen savers your
kids face that's always a problem but
like you know you got to dot your i's
and cross your T's when I'm whacking off
it I use my iPad and then later on and
fill your belly I don't like my kids
want to like borrow into something yeah
yeah and I'm just like I always this is
scary cuz I always I'm good with clear
into history and then I X out of the box
but then sometimes I'll go I'll put it
on later on and I put on the safari
right away [ __ ] his vagina or it is
fun yeah you gotta give it an iPad man
yeah you can or pov whatever you're into
but but your POV if they're leaving
that's the point of view
40 years old hon could there's the door
hi so enthusiastic though like oh yeah
soccer moms not that old not likes a big
light to the right that one right there
yeah for nine long I'm married I don't
you happily married
nobody's do anything for me you like a
big heininger right oh did I do it right
there what's that ball you don't come on
right what what old lady with the
glasses and miserable jerk and a poker
bet Matt what were you watching on VR oh
wait hold on one second just looking at
the [ __ ] lady that old yeah you saying
oh yes what yes let me tell you
something about my single days speak on
it sometimes whether they're old or that
heavy you got to fight in the open
weight class quality Paul Williams
jerking somebody off your mom is so fast
I don't know I definitely would go older
than younger really me too
what about older than me I mean older in
general it's it's part of your world
don't like your friends not that you do
this but like there's you see a lot of
moms a lot that's a hot little subject a
nice you know some some neighborhood
picking up your kids I get coffee then
are you married yeah I mean ah nothing
you would do outside of the room that's
the floor pad over there
yeah he's very young you like young porn
right you know yeah okay
you like Sam Roberts I like not young
young oh yeah yeah yeah you don't mix in
your hobbies what you're pouring right
surprised your wife and here's the same
hair China made in China made a porn and
it was it was a long wrestling there's
sexy did you watch it I liked our big
clip you didn't I love it I like
muscular chicks sometimes I like there's
only so much muscle girl porn you could
find because a lot of times it is no
there's a lot of guys head between their
thighs and they're flexing I don't give
a [ __ ] wait you like legislation Jimmy
to the bodybuilder girl she rest in
peace
you like that man do it what the angry
face you like that better than the
Japanese crying porn you do I don't need
to hear that [ __ ] no I like I like I
wanna look at me no yeah yeah like I
should I guess I had a five hour before
I got here 5-hour energy I don't want
these girls don't watch I don't want you
because they blur it out they blur the
penis out and and the hairy but you can
tell you that's like I have some areas
bushes though he likes a hairy bush that
[ __ ] loves a hair
[Music]
why bench striking coach yeah my former
coach and my buddy ray Longo go to
Dodger champions are you guys partners
already just work together
my friends I knew I was 17 he's a good
dude he's trying to me my whole career
you know ray Longo who loves Harry Bush
I don't like Japanese uh I don't like
that because they blur out the [ __ ]
they do they do a lot of crying
really yeah they have a lot of weird
porn - it's like this is it the guy who
just jerks off behind a paper and then
throws it at girls faces at a bus stop
and I don't know if it's real or just I
don't know it's just weird like
Toleration yeah you know but it took a
guy's just sitting the jerking off in
the girls at the train or whatever and
he just throws it in her face and she's
like what doll father see some video of
the autism video of the report the
crying poor any audio of that I don't
know I don't want to see if I mean
they're all adults I don't get it
let's hear it was here well I take it
back this one's this girl's hot though
chummy legs you don't like a little
thickness she's crying in the morning I
don't like mr. Miyagi that's not a
crying no bad girl
up but she's crying she's [ __ ]
ridiculous she's crying this is just
better one that's making me horny
this is Japanese whimpering porn we
bring one day go it's terrible
why she's moaning if it didn't say
crying she's in pain what I like the
close-up face that's fun you having a
good time man Sarah OH
you guys were party up in here I don't
get the crying thing though like well
how would that say anybody aren't they
only here yeah bad like a Michael
Jackson Jackson nipples depends what
you're into man I don't like them and
Sam I said just white and then just
really I like it I don't like areola I
don't know like a pink areola yeah have
you ever been with a Filipino girl no
I'm sure I have happily no no that's not
for you anymore you don't like that a
most into a Italian milf wait you watch
me i watch porn i watch like you know
tell you milf italian mom I like that
too Matt I like when the girl comes in
the mom comes in it's your son's best
friend yeah hey where's Joey
I don't know well let me tell you yeah
all right forget Joey ah [ __ ] Joey
but another lifetime ago Filipino porn
would have been your [ __ ] oh yeah
another lifetime a lifetime ago yeah
that would have been great brazilian
Brazilian mature like - you are 40 plus
just to make sure
well it feels more real right it feels
more like it could really happen like
you could get a 40 plus yeah right I get
that I can get a 40 for the young girls
might be too cuz I'm full of personality
but you like banging it you'd like
fantasize about banging a chick who
doesn't know what Twitter is or social
media
who's the one Twitter I'm barely on it
attacked the Vice I do I do
well Jimmy Jimmy's the most popular
probably no I get I get you can bring
Mike it Mike is here oh nice to bring my
cat yeah sure yeah my Chinese comedian I
think whoever whoever is the most
followers probably is the one who gets
attacked the most that's right it's just
what you do watch with me oh no though
some some like actors don't get attacked
that's true really he's got a thick skin
though yeah I am she could bother me not
bother because somebody's talking should
I have somebody filter
my Twitter though I don't see any of
them like that there's a button you can
just hit and you don't see any of that
[ __ ] what's up Mike the negativity good
nice sure we're just talking about porn
and then tweets that we don't like
seeing yeah I like that rice moking a
blunt that's nice some people are
negative on Twitter yeah man Sarah I
mean he is fired out of a goddamn cannon
this morning oh yeah you are all energy
I think it's a bad thing
normal thing for me Jimmy I'm preparing
Mike who's gonna win McGregor or
Mayweather who's gonna win yeah who's
eating McGregor can do it he could take
him out no well look to think that this
is the thing in a Rio obviously and I
know it's a boxing match
he's got the he's got the mind going in
as far as with no pressure
he has no pressure on him the pressure
is all on Floyd if it goes the distance
even if it's a shutout
why aren't you you should be able to
take this guy out you tell me you can't
take this guy out here that you're not
much of a different level that you can't
take out this guy who never had a
professional boxing match
well [ __ ] and now look if he's gonna do
that he can't stay in his normal shell
and he doesn't want to do a repeat of
the Manny Pacquiao fight even said he
wants to make up for that but doesn't he
care as much once the tickets are bought
he doesn't give a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's
kind of give a [ __ ] I can't say oh my
god I gave you try but it's so cool the
way he says it but uh and listen also he
has important a couple years he's 40
years old I mean you know these are
things that take in consideration and if
he wants to if he goes in there with the
mindset like a look I want to take I
want to make an example of Conor put
this guy away make me make myself look
Oh awesome
whenever you try to put a tweak a fight
you know not not in his normal style
does it affect okay Connor goes in wins
[ __ ] out did that hurt boxing
I mean I'm I mean if I mean it doesn't
hurt if Connor loses it doesn't hurt UFC
but if Connor goes in knocks out the
best of the best
takes him the [ __ ] out in under four
rounds like he says he's gonna do
I mean that hurts boxing well doesn't
even defend his belt after that like
this counter box again or is this the
only I mean look at the payday yeah I
know how do you go back to you know the
money in mixed martial arts isn't isn't
like that
nowhere near that kind of always say
that he wanted to make a whole bunch of
money and get out quick yep
he said he wants to I was getting
surprised me if he retired and I opened
a gym or did a bunch of business
ventures or whatever I say the same
thing about comedy then again he made
[ __ ] he may want a piece of the UFC
he may fight again if he has a little
piece of the company to him but I mean
on all that all that stuff that's going
against Floyd Mayweather at the same
time he's a professional boxer that's 49
and oh yeah like you know I mean if
you're like the smart pick would be in a
boxing match obviously is is Floyd right
like I'm not that guy he's because you
know I want Conor do well be like he's
gonna knock him out but could he
I think he's extremely accurate and he's
got hands he's got [ __ ] hands and he
knows how to place shots and all it
takes is one so if Floyd says all right
this guy's not on my level I can open up
a little more and he goes to hurt him
you put yourself out there to get hurt
because he has to go he has Conor has to
go and [ __ ] in the rules dirty fight
this guy as much as you can he has to go
in and beat this guy up make it a brawl
because if he tries to box in his [ __ ]
right you can't throw his karate chops
like he normally does is that what he
usually yeah because it's martial arts
yes yeah that's cool karate kicks Roddy
kicks right there's a clause that if he
throws any of that [ __ ] he gets nothing
yeah yeah if he throws any karate chop
one karate kick anymore I'm surprised if
you see him do some funny [ __ ] like some
crap where I dancing in there and she's
gonna do some Bruce Lee show he's gonna
be doing some stuff just the kind of
[ __ ] around isn't gonna wear boxer
shorts or a karate uniform Agee Floyd
whose I'm [ __ ] Mayweather just
clarifying for the audience
[Laughter]
Floyd Mayweather thank you Jim he he's
[ __ ] rollerskating
he's rollerskating he's doing all the
silly [ __ ] taking breaks that's just to
get people to buy the pay-per-view cuz
they want people to think Conor has a
better shot that's a 100% it's a [ __ ]
they said he's going to strip clubs a
lot do you think Mayweather's going to
strip clubs one but he's not doing that
the fight week but also by all accounts
he's training and hasn't lost the step
like everybody's that what that's
watched him has been like this guy looks
like he's 29 years old it's ridiculous
people just to go hey maybe boys not
training is hard Connor could it's all
fight promotion do when you get hit with
a punch now I have about not you oh well
back then donkey punch Jimmy does it I
mean it's it's different than it used to
be I mean it [ __ ] you up to China stuck
in nine dicks up the old Matt Serra and
forgot to click out it's just funny that
you could name all the faces this angry
face there's [ __ ] who are you
confused face that's comedy they're
different
oh god you know nine different pictures
in one headshot yeah I used to bang this
Magnus girl back in the day he was this
kind of girl like a like a big muscle
girl like the glow wrestling with a
change like that I look behind you
that's a bitter clip suck that till the
cows came home some [ __ ]
with the girls riding me right on my Fox
in this room this girl's riding me
without my shirt on let me tell you
about this [ __ ] big [ __ ] I was banging
so she was she was strong like a China
chick she was she'd used to train on the
west coast and visit us and
[Laughter]
[Music]
the cat he took the photo of Bob Kelly
and Matt Saracen next to each other in
between heroes born after we all do but
he's got those Tigers I had the sound
effects what did you say we really do
have the three students Larry and Moe
you wish that you you're upset that you
don't have the sound effects all right
go ahead
I always say don't throw water on my
face and charge me for piss I like dicks
that's Sam I think I look powerful in
this picture I feel so bloated right now
oh come on you look good I look like I'm
looking at at I'm looking at a new me
and I'm mad ahead to what I could do
[Laughter]
disgusted by my if I just had willpower
oh you're looking at your potential and
getting mad yeah just looking like I
could do I can't [ __ ] be that all I
know is nobody's ever gonna believe that
I'm the after pick guys fatter than both
of us summer summer Sam happened
yeah I do a summer slam week do you
really that's what I do man what you do
tell me about this big [ __ ] that you
were [ __ ] yeah yeah strong like that
strong she's riding me she gave me a
nice the [ __ ] open hand hit to the
face I told you before jig now she hit
me she was you want me to do that again
she was like [ __ ] a bass root and
[ __ ] palm strike
meet you again attack that wasn't a
great story but it got interrupted 20
times China would come all over us you
know like being slapped LEP uh turn me
off a bit I like something a little more
knuckle II be sharper yeah the female on
medius I like a good slap to the face it
feels good like when they grab your face
real rough and make you lick oh thank
you like why Nick what job to do still
have to jerk yourself off while you're
being I guess so yeah that's the whole
thing why did you slap slap by dicks and
why are you looking through your own
bookmarks just finding your own gay porn
yeah don't sign into your own pornhub
account what do you like about that is
the eye contact they're maintaining what
did you like about that Troy I didn't
even read everything I just loved that
the hips had no definition they went
from the armpit right to the bus talking
about those no light slaps white Troy on
Troy it looks like to Dennis Reynolds
from always sunny [ __ ] game Rob just
was talking about it I didn't see you I
waiting come on China this is my legit
first time watching gay porn I've seen
meat spin calm I used to set that as
like homepages in college yes ah sofas
but this is the first time I like meat
spin before the whole [ __ ] music I
put to it I was familiar with it with
her work on any given day try can't find
anything anywhere on the internet but
today he's the gay porn king it really
is come on you found that gay porn
take off the [ __ ] meat spits actually
just mentioned meats doing the right
thing you get yelled at us no I just
like to gay porn alone muscular girls
guys but with a [ __ ] I do like haha
muscle chicks muscle chick I like muscle
chicks but only if they have the big
[ __ ] like a body but I like the big [ __ ]
yeah I do like a muscle check into that
I've been a head of quite a few there
big lips have even throat oh my god he
spells muscle wrong no how did you spell
myself M us SL a boy no that was good
core now go back to that one that was
good right down the bottom there right
there that's why I'm gonna do something
listen to the chip podcast on a road
trip for the first time ever and she was
in she was furious
oh great for the entire trip it made me
so delighted and then yesterday I heard
her drop something go is that time
Ashley chambers I just pulled my
hamstring
did you trying to straighten out my legs
that Ashley chambers I think that losses
losses this is just people watching porn
now what's your name no no actually
audio
we're just watching two lesbian
bodybuilders yeah it's indefensible when
the angry tweets come in there's there's
nothing I would apologize it's guys
watch we were putting our spin on it
like we weren't we were just walking off
pekka's did you guys do that as kids
like ever like yup first our
masturbating you got in a room with your
friends and put on some porn yes I did
you know my owner I literally did it me
and my friend who trade sucks like you
if you suck by 10 times I would I you're
10 sucks no you did oh yeah we did
that's not a joke how many sucks you get
up to we didn't come back that were too
young you're like eight years old
yeah and you're trading sucks with your
friend yes I was like why would you even
think I don't remember who started the
whole thing but think of the whole
neighborhood involved with all of us can
you name your next yeah um Trading sucks
yeah trading Sachs is by the way I mean
it's funny whoever thought of it the
reason you can't remember who thought of
it is because it wasn't one of the
neighborhood kids that thought of it it
was someone much older
I remember you do it you would do it
just to get it done like I remember my
one friend I did it to him and he didn't
wanna do it back cause like what the
[ __ ] instead of like 20 cards instead of
trading cards
oh [ __ ] like that you traded sucks
that's it I played pogs I call hogs no
they were almost no they're from Edison
and I left Edison in the beginning of
fourth grade I remember anybody's name
[Laughter]
cinema thing one suck
sucks of your friends was there one who
was the best at training socks like was
there one like no I'm gonna trace Ashton
I want sucks from him I think so yeah
yeah everybody everybody wanted Norton
yeah Jimmy the mouth girls the play wait
why they scared me a little bit I found
them eventually they were all so random
the game yeah now didn't your piss
fetish start with a young girl like like
very like when you were young a young
boy and girl with their brother and
sister what was it
they both pee their pants a lot I guess
they got beaten up at home I didn't know
that I would get them individually
behind the bushes to sit on my face that
their pants do I just wish I could smell
it so they piss their pants they're
killed with you Jimmy second grade holy
he's eight years old another eight year
old pisses their pants and he's trying
to go and get them to go in the bushes
to sit on his face with their clothes on
I won't judge Jimmy you can't right I
can't listen he was born this way
obviously he know he was the way he was
molested into it he wasn't born now I
don't think so boy I do
no I'm afraid shocks and you don't think
you were molested nobody just one of the
suck it and counts number let's
experiment exactly it's fun and it's
math that's just a little boy
experimenting with his ding-ding they
said that the squirting is mostly just
pissed it's not I've tasted it's not a
cumbia once and we had a girl squirt
into Bobo's Cup he missed most of it but
then we tested the actual liquid and it
was about 98% piss oh is it really yeah
Wow you know what the taste is different
for some reason maybe it tastes like a
clear pain most girls Steve also said
that - he ain't corroborated but you
guys looked at the chemicals friend of
the show you guys looked at the
chemicals in the makeup of it to really
gauge what this is and Jim is just doing
taste testing at the factory for 30
years
this is like window you mean I like
Pepsi business so money so more year
piss you have a lot of squirters
I've only had a couple I only had one I
made a girl squirt not long ago and and
she's in her 30s and she said no guy had
ever made her squirt and I ate her [ __ ]
and she squirted it but that was that
was an odd one short you ever make a
girl squirt how'd you do it [ __ ] her
sorrel fingers all fingers about yeah
Troy those tricks the mother I had sex
with when I worked at a gymnastic your
mother yeah where was your dad he left
and therefore I was taking care of my
mom but I know she she went a long way
or her husband was like in prison and
stuff like that and she was one of those
like inste comers and I guess around the
you know multiple times she actually
squirted on the [ __ ] vault it was
great it was in the gymnastic know that
moms kids I tried to have sex with her
daughter after that that's why I got
fired galaxy gymnastics in orange town
shout out yeah shout out how long was
the mom she wasn't in the early 20s when
she I was I was 20 and on steroids she
was like 40 45 wow you're in steroids
yeah sure well he might get bigger guy
than you he appears to because he wears
loose shirts
yeah well I'm right now I'm kind of
emaciated and trying to you know really
taking were you taking this nothing just
pop Jones for no I was taking like so
they would sell it over the counter
while it was going through the FDA
process and then as soon as it got
rejected they would take it down change
the label and a molecule and then put it
back yeah we talked about that oh yeah I
took an wa m1t methyl D and I also took
clenbuterol which is like a horse asthma
medication and that builds lean mass and
like makes you shake like a [ __ ]
maniac but how long before I should take
some for a while yeah I mean like I did
three cycles I got up to like 205 and
like five and a half percent body fat I
one cycle Matt er tea or tea that
wouldn't kill me and not for nothing I
know it doesn't help you dick doesn't
even look I went I got tested and they
said of my my test was like 300 and I
supposedly low so then I got on it and
it's [ __ ] awesome testosterone right
I never did anything like when I was
obviously you couldn't do this when you
were fighting and whatnot but I'm
retired and it I should look WAY worse
man I eat a lot of pizza and cake I roll
I do a lot of jujitsu but I eat [ __ ]
I've been eating [ __ ] let me ask you a
question well you get tits if you stop
taking
No you have to take if you take you they
give you stuff where uh like there's
like a like a one little like tiny
little pill you cut with that little
pill machine you take one of the I
forget the names of this [ __ ] but this
stuff you take that will block it I took
that five total yeah I go look man I'm
five six already don't give me titties I
don't need to be a little short guy with
tits maybe I'll take CRT I hear it's
good for sure it's not gonna hurt you I
told you get you a little hairier though
and you got old go I don't like here I'm
a smooth boy yes you are yes you are we
have to strength using right right in
there I get a needle in my ass different
every week by the doc what are you doing
don't know no I can't can't do that I
can't do that like that I have to do it
my leg your life rescue life don't have
to I can get weaned off it how long is
one cycle and by the way I you can't get
a well I don't want to put any false
information out there but I shut down
your factory so like I could like like
not pull out and like I'm not getting
any I do anyway I just lie about my name
so what uh like if I wanna have a kid
again I think it off it yeah and I don't
why I have three kids so I'm [ __ ]
that ship has sailed anyway so but it
does is nice though that's another you
get tested and [ __ ] like that as far as
like an exam and I'm nearly as often as
I should check up I mean every six seven
weeks I get blood taken I give blood
because you're supposed to give blood
when you do it and I think I'm healthier
for it if I just laid off that [ __ ]
pizza and cake I'd be a [ __ ] machine
so good though bean cake I wish they
sold it in the same place pizza and cake
yeah what a great business cake that's
Carpinteria just get a piece of pizza
and a nice little piece of cake yeah I
would go to a Pizza Hut Carvel way more
than Dunkin Donuts Carvel Oh Pizza eat
the dessert but it's not as good it's
not it's not saying it's not the same
you get one of those little chocolate
cakes but it's different yeah it's
different you know it's not bad the
Domino is they give those little lava
cake things that look like a flower
those good you know for dominoes
Domino's in fact it's like a guilty like
pleasure where it's like you don't want
to really like admit you like it a lot
of that [ __ ] no I love bread I love that
[ __ ] I get cheesy bread it means like
[ __ ] taste I have anything so long
but Matt talks about it so much on the
podcast like I really want to get yeah
Pizza Pizza tips on the UFC but I really
want to go for pizza I got two slices of
John's last week I was shooting I got an
episode of that crashing the dome show
it was like 10:00 in the morning I went
to John how are two slices the best
[ __ ] pizza and the planet Earth let's
definitely going buy a pie there what's
that no you go you can buy slices yeah
Louisiana Joe's Joe's what I say Johnson
yeah John's is all right Joseph josh is
good Joe's I'm sorry Joe Joe is the
place calling like yeah what's the best
recipient Collins at dinner last weekend
he kept trying get me to go to Joe's I'm
like I can't eat that so good
wait wait you can't even shock your
system once in a while if you have it if
you won't eat it what it's good for you
I'm serious
you [ __ ] question booze I go straight
to pizza yeah straight to pizza better
for you probably pizza right I would
assume because every time I just lost
five pounds since Monday because I
stopped drinking I'm not a big drinker
and I don't either
plus you can't die from a pizza driving
it yes you can I guess I'm not the
passionate what is the pizza place in
Mamaroneck South is it it's great it's
the best it's better than any place in
the city
isn't there a hotdog place over there
too yeah Walters it's also better than
any hot dog in the city Craig
yep you don't like Chris dog Walter's is
the best hot dog in New York I heard all
you have to bait I know is sometimes
Walters just about is it better than
Gray's papaya pizzeria right there
sounds in Mamaroneck is the best pizza
in the state maybe the country better
than Frank Pepe in Connecticut yes oh
all I know is the next episode of I know
Jimmy likes to know about this next
episode of Deena white looking for a
fight that thing I do on YouTube that
show I do
yeah we're visiting we do a New York
episode they didn't come out yet it's
coming out I believe next month and we
is it all like three different pizzeria
is the best ones John's was one of them
she got a thousand Mamaroneck [ __ ] with
the Joe's we have to go with the Joe's
to with Joe's man with the Joe's and
went to D is right around the corner
ready original what am I thinking of
Lombardi's or Umberto's we did something
that was the first pizzeria ever famous
Ray's I like famous race not bad I also
there's no grease lot there's a little
spot near here on the corner called
Sbarro's yeah that's a good yeah away
III own Chicago pizza yeah that's gonna
copy Chicago pizza
everything that's pizza dough is not no
good Afonso copy was the best my kago
pizzas my brother-in-law sent me over
some pizza like she shipped it from
Chicago and it was one of those it was
[ __ ] it was [ __ ] delicious delicious
pizza do you like deep-dish pizza a
slice a deep-dish yeah where do you get
it from me - there's it's a local spot I
like that sure you get an appetizer for
my thanks you don't like that man
there's no way you like deep-dish sure
Joey D that's good no way that's awesome
Tom Tom thanks this is far more excited
than you were from the port it really
super fly smoker over there
he died in a car accident
yeah I'm sorry I don't want you to find
out that way of course Hulk Hogan's Rock
and wrestling yeah jy DS dead junkyard
ah he's dead
thank God Macho Man still around in
current on that that's [ __ ] good yeah
you don't want now
I [ __ ] hate chip don't like you know
chip man I don't know I love Jimmy but I
want to smack that [ __ ] chip yeah
does he ever go in to chip on the UFC
pot God often close to minute do you
think anybody's gonna end up doing a
Photoshop of chips era they do they do
Fran they do Photoshop of all of our
guests I don't know what makes a chip
Sarah photos shame you I found a picture
you dude I was going through my hard
drive I found I found a picture you and
Brazil chubby chubby Norton holding a
vibrator and a dildo remember Patrice is
vibrator yeah I found that picture dude
I gotta send it to you it what a great
photo of you sitting there like this
like you're like you're just want to
trophy my family's Chinese [ __ ] over my
shoulder and you've got my kids down no
you don't have this photo dude look at
Jim in a bathrobe ow who's that
that's Patrice Oh Jimmy no the girl up
the top I know Theresa is using comedian
he's passed away that was a Brazilian
girl like China's clear in that picture
that's some Brazilian that's a Brazilian
girl in the one of the hotel rooms
pretty yeah she showed you guys are
boobs yep that's no boob
we got it shut up in person yeah shut up
I got it
I like that picture that picture down
there and me and him got Batman look at
her boob where where that's right there
oh my god that's right Accord dinner
that's when Laura Bush spoke and Patrice
was heckling Laura Bush your husband's
gonna get us all killed doing stand-up
now George Bush yeah which one I forget
Harvey the one who was on The Today Show
right a comedy club a few weeks really
yeah huh well I guess I guess enough
time is passed people are not viscerally
angry at her and now he seems like a
goddamn peach right right in comparison
and writing that she got arrested for
whatever underage drinking thinking
about that Noren I forgot you a fat
aye-aye-aye find pictures you want to
know I'm like what the [ __ ]
it is amazing cuz looking at you now you
don't look capable of it like you look
as though you belong at the weight
you're at yeah I feel good at this way
you know it's funny when I was when I
was fat I knew I was fat but when I saw
that special I did for HBO that was that
was the 2006 and all over to the right
oh my god right one more one more
keep going know that one but I'm making
it face there that's the what the one
the go away to the right for the along
that one's worse that's just me talking
[ __ ] and he looks terrible were you
there the third one in he looks terrible
that's 11 years ago that one I was about
38 looks horrible picture no no go back
the other way
look at that lucky Louie picture me one
of them
yeah that's yeah see you Robin Williams
Robin Wayne was with a lesbian comedian
Wow
yeah I look like the [ __ ] cartoon of
a Vedika member the mice would do hey
bad bad I don't want to get negative
goes a long picture last professionals
right next to Robin fat [ __ ] I was all
right all right that's the last day of
shooting for Jimmy the payment Pamela
still looks the same
she looks like a [ __ ] pimp drinking
his hannel sexy rick has looked like a
pirate since like forever huh yes other
professions now I got three comics in
the room okay why do you guys kill
yourself so many times rific no killer
shoves oh not you obviously know like
there's only been like one I mean right
yeah I know I know
six comedians have committed suicide
rise to Matt's point known comedians no
with a James
Jenny Robin and that's it yeah I mean I
don't know any I don't know RINs
oh I didn't know Freddie back home sorry
yeah hung himself I didn't know right
- family few home song himself
I hit yourself in the head with I don't
know got my head hurts maybe you were
hitting yourself in the head of the rock
yeah oh yeah I think right did Troy Troy
does it show how he died
reg reg Holmes ah agent 40 yeah you know
what it says right under he was a hung
himself and then when his body fell a
rock fell on his head yes oh yeah
Richard did it didn't say long does it
tell you why not himself
that's ten years ago yeah I was in the I
was in the green room at the Pittsburgh
improv and Rogan called me that's how I
found out he died Joe Rogan called me
ten years ago with a psychotic paranoia
that's what it is I think there's a lot
of accidental suicides where it's like
because they're self-medicating it kind
of happens yeah isn't gonna make me OD
if anything alcohol might kill Jenny
called me one time he was drunk I think
he was drunk and he called me on the
phone he was really depressed and he was
like man he'd do some message board that
was bashing him he's like they're
bashing man especially Boyd they're
calling me a hack on Lloyd time we get
him to stop it I'm like dude you're
[ __ ] you're a brilliant comic what are
you talking about like it bothered him
because he wasn't used to the beginning
of his social media that message board
this was yeah you started you you got up
until then social media you just got
love cuz you showed up
the fans were there and who you know and
now you get a [ __ ] deal with hecklers
that you can't see hecklers that you
can't see but also some of them like you
and they're [ __ ] just trying to be
funny you don't really have to deal I
mean the trick is to not [ __ ] thing
check your Twitter reply obsessively you
put that [ __ ] face on you know like
chip [ __ ] hate you
hey it's like a high-five on the eight
and chip do you think karate kicks I
wish it was on this list because Chris
Rock said something really funny about
Chris Rock says know what I'm about be
to community goes you know how they say
ignorance is bliss he goes that's what
he goes comedians notice everything
that's why we're miserable there's a
conversation well hypersensitive to
everything because everything could be a
potential joke we'd take everything
apart somebody says something to us a
waitress walks over goes how you doing
and we're like what the [ __ ] wrong
with her everybody was like she said how
you doing no it's the way she [ __ ]
said it and then we rip it apart you
have somebody fighting everything that's
said to us everything that's done we try
to well and it's like you're that's a
born insensitivity to because that's
that helped curate your sense of humor
as a defense mechanism so that Center
activity has been around and it kind of
heightens as you go along in your career
and then eventually you know it could be
an overload later in life the people
when you become more sensitive later in
life later in life you become more
sensitive because as you get older
things mean more to you and then all of
a sudden you [ __ ] have all these
people that out things your career
you just [ __ ] them out did you try
I'm gone you do get more emotional when
you get old you do yeah kids I became a
little bit more because you can actually
you connected to somebody you connected
to something so that wasn't like a big
[ __ ]
yeah well are you a crier Matt I'll tear
it about his leg when I talk about my
kids I did I become a big puss well you
you like because you think about you how
much you love them and how they're
growing on to explain in Germany no I
was making the water bottle he's not
connect he's a serial killer he doesn't
get holes kid you don't get much he
doesn't know you're away at a [ __ ]
wrestling retreat I hit my family he
will cut you right now he will cut them
out
you call sorry I'm late cut out on
Twitter sorry somebody somebody sent out
by naming Farley's Network I guess they
got into her profile but look what they
got somebody that his body MacFarlane
has a net worth of four hundred thousand
dollars she co-hosts the podcast my wife
hates me with her husband rich Voss who
is Richard Jeni was just message boards
and on celebrity worth it says rich boss
[Laughter]
I'm connected with my family did they do
chips error yet maybe they make chip
with all of our guests they got a good
Chip Kelly one where they put chips face
on on everyone every guess we have like
how often you cry men's probably like
crying that's the question I cry with
him on outfit if I'm away or something I
think they got me talking or something
there died me on an episode get me a
little I got a little choked up because
I've been away from my kids for like a
week and then they they ask you
questions talk to it soon you get like
you miss them what I'm gonna [ __ ] cry
nice for them today but I don't even
remember your family I don't what am I
gonna cry about my family because you're
alright you miss them I see them all all
the time see most of the football now
cry over like a wrestling match yeah
even bother [ __ ] yeah did you cry
over a wrestling match Sam I can't
imagine but I can't look I've seen a lot
of wrestling for a lot of years tears of
joy
maybe tears of joy maybe tears of
inspiration I don't know would you right
away get one match like this fights I
have that stick out my head I really
enjoy is it one wrestling match you're
like God man
orgasmic tell me quick I mean there's
tons of I'd say I know the WrestleMania
13 submission match between Bret the
Hitman Hart and Stone Cold Steve Austin
she's watching the double turn that's
what a red heart turns heel Austin turns
face all in the course of one match this
guy's bleeding
he won't submit finally the referee just
has to call it cuz he's passed out
there's blood everywhere I mean it's
what about the Undertaker mankind cage
match the Hell in a Cell yeah well
that's just like watching a guy that's
that's basically watching Gore porn like
that's just watching a guy destroy the
Iron Sheik was fighting against Bob
Backlund that's what that's the end of
that conversation I think wow Bob
Backlund was fighting us is it up quite
the Iron Sheik was fighting for the
Iranian - suddenly you and sergeant
slaughter well here's the thing [ __ ] him
man I met him one time at the Carnegie
Deli it's a wonderful place have you
ever been there - closed down
unfortunately oh no I of course was not
a fan of sergeant slaughter while he was
an Iraqi sympathizer during Desert Storm
but then he went back to the American
South time for America then he went back
to America and that was enough time for
all of us right right and me but they
got four Hulk Hogan oh god what's really
said is we have different reasons why we
hate him he wrote a GI Joe for me as a
kid
why do you i Joe cuz he obviously he was
gotta know so GI Joe they were special
the best dispel is your kid you know you
looking at these ghetto action figure
stuff and you read on the back all this
one's a expert in this - the baddest
[ __ ] they're also you have this
fat [ __ ] I'm gonna train you guys in the
car - and they make him all diesel but
then the real scar just Laura he's like
in between commercial breaks all fat and
everything and he's and he's and he's
like and also he beats up all the GIS I
give you all attack him and it ruined
everything
why he's been out he's joining us water
was tougher than GI Joe the [ __ ] you
be happy you'll be happy to learn that
apparently so they wanted to make him
like the human GI Joe like they made him
and he's wrestling at the time for WWF
and he goes and he's like they want me
to do this and then they're like what
you can't engage me will be on GI Joe
you're our sergeant slaughter not theirs
that's right so he actually had to leave
wrestling to do GI Joe yeah because they
would not let him Wow so what is it he's
really got Lauren Cooper
[Laughter]
the character that England that's a
reference to my show stones me I don't
like it you got it
staying in character Ronnie think and
mold over to another show it's
ridiculous right they have the same
mustache
[Laughter]